this video is sponsored by skillshare
hybrid exercises are exercises that
combine two or maybe three movements
into a single repetition beyond that
you'd maybe be talking about a flow
these tend to be performed in a slightly
more rhythmic and slower manner whereas
a hybrid exercise tends to be a little
bit more explosive performed almost as
though it was just one single movement
just made up of more pieces hybrid
exercises and flows are some of the very
best ways you can train we're going to
talk about why that is in this video I'm
going to be sharing some of my favorite
examples you can try yourself as well as
a few ideas for you to experiment with
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so right away one of the best advantages
of a hybrid exercise is of course the
simple fact
that you're getting more bang for your
buckets time efficient instead of doing
two exercises separately and getting the
benefits that way you're going to do all
of them in one go and that way get more
benefits in less time and there are some
trade-offs which we'll talk about as we
go but on the whole
it's just simply
better value so in case you're thinking
this was going to be all weird exercises
it's really not in fact you probably
already familiar with a whole bunch of
different hybrid exercises a great
example is the Burpee the Burpee is a
push-up combined with a squat jump and
that way you're getting the benefits of
both to a large extent the Burpee is
great because you can also combine it
with a bunch of other exercises as we'll
see in a moment
I'm gonna do a few here because it's
really cold and wet I need to build up
some resilience warm up a little bit
start to get a bit half wild and a buffy
is particularly fantastic for cardio as
are many hybrid exercises and the reason
is that you're alternating using your
legs and then your upper body which
means that the blood needs to circulate
all the way around the body there's a
kind of shunting effect going on where
your heart has to drive the blood to the
legs drive it to the pecs and back down
again you're using more muscle to
perform these exercises they're truly
compound and therefore you're going to
be burning a lot more calories getting a
lot more out of breath as long as you're
using good form as long as you don't
have any existing back issues for
example there's no reason you can't do
these for hundreds of repetitions like
they do in the military they do it for a
reason an example of a move that's great
to combine with the Burpee and something
you see me do a lot on this channel is
the kick through
if you watch this channel there's a
chance you're interested in
self-development in that case you'll
probably be interested in today's
sponsor skillshare
skillshare is a learning platform that
offers thousands of classes and members
from 150 different countries the cool
thing about skillshare is that the
classes are made by members of the
community themselves experts in any
field can share their knowledge with the
audience providing a huge amount of high
quality information working on this
channel I need to wear many hats I have
to be a presenter a coach a videographer
an editor a graphic designer a marketer
a businessman a web developer
skillshare has helped me to learn and
develop all of these skills and help me
to grow the channel to where it is today
as a result right now I'm interested in
developing my animation and 3D modeling
further a great series that's been
helping me in that regard is anyone can
animate easy animation for social media
by Danny cassale a great takeaway from
this series is that animation doesn't
need to be complicated you can make
something really simple using basic
tools and that's then a great entry
point into the world of animation
skillshare is completely ad-free with
new premium classes added each week the
entire back catalog can now also be
viewed with Spanish French Portuguese
and German subtitles so if you're
interested in leveling up your learning
then check out skillshare using the link
below the first 1000 people to use the
link will get a one month free trial of
skillshare
and now on with the show so basically
going to kick your leg underneath to one
side whilst you're doing a push-up
you're getting more rotation in there
and that's the reason I really like this
because rotating the core and building
that transverse power is something that
you don't get to do a lot of if you do
purely body weight exercise I think
throwing in kicks can be a great way to
do this actually but for our purposes
here a great option is to include kick
throughs with your burpees and that way
get some rotation you're training now in
two different planes of motion at the
same time doing one exercise that's bang
for your buck
there are many other reasons this is
just good stuff as well we're training
in multiple planes here with multiple
different movements with switching
movements this is just a much more
complex exercise than just say doing
push-ups or just squat jumps or even
just kick threes that means you need to
pay more attention it's more cognitively
demanding this makes it instantly more
engaging triggers the release of more
neurotrophic factors that are going to
encourage more brain plasticity we need
to train in a way that's engaging it
makes us more like to do it we keep
things cognitively stimulating not just
taxing for the muscles but for the brain
as well that's the best kind of training
at the same time it requires more
proprioception and you're dealing with
the momentum of your own body in this
way you're almost turning your whole
body into a kettlebell as you have to
not only position and contract the
muscles you also have to deal with
things like the fact that you're moving
forwards and you think about the next
movement it's just so much more Dynamic
and that's how I use our strength in the
real world I mean not like that
specifically most of us don't have need
to do like a kick through then a push-up
when we're going down the aisle at the
supermarkets but in terms of moving from
one position to another out of sequence
not just repeating the same movement
over and over again in a very
predictable manner yes this is how we
use our bodies there are a ton of
additional movements and exercises we
can throw into the mix here in
particular push-ups lend themselves
really well to this sort of thing
because with a push-up you can also do
things like clapping push-ups you do
things like lizard crawls you can do
things like even jumping up into a
handstand if you're capable all these
different movements can be linked
together at this point you're taking it
Beyond just a hybrid exercise you're
taking it Beyond even a flow because
we're doing a more explosive Manner and
we're doing it with creativity we're not
following a set routine I like to dig
from a pool of different exercises that
I know Target similar muscle groups and
I call these Vector sets they're far
more expressive and they can be a lot
more fun a lot more engaging and still
very challenging and tactic for the
muscles in terms of pull-ups of course
this also applies to a pull-up bar you
can do any variation of pull-ups whether
it's a typewriter pull up a head banger
around the world leg raises pull ups
chin UPS clapping pull-ups you see
people like bar Stars doing this and it
looks absolutely awesome you don't have
to go that far to vary your pull-ups
within a single set pick two and combine
them to create hybrid movement or pick
loads and make a vector set and how do
you get up there you could even perform
a burpee jump up grab the bar that way
you can mingle your push-ups your
pull-ups your squats all into one
seamless flow
another great hybrid exercise you might
have already heard of and be familiar
with is the muscle up this is both a
vertical pull and vertical push great
for core strength and a great party
trick plus there are loads of variations
and ways you can develop on it whether
it's with rings muscle up Etc just a
great movement to incorporate and then
of course you can take it one step
further by alternating between muscle
ups and a bunch of other movements where
they're doing presses at the top of the
bar whether you want to do clapping
pull-ups in between reps or some kind of
other cool move
you can just experiment with it
endlessly
in terms of squats there's of course
nothing to prevent you from switching
between multiple body weight squat
variations I've talked about the
benefits of a regular deep squat with
your heels flat I've talked about the
benefits of squatting on the balls of
your feet like a Hindu squat why not mix
them up and get all those benefits
whatever you fancy
again this is the way we actually use
our bodies and our strength and we have
to really use them in the real world if
you're playing a sport you don't just
perform a kick a kick a kick a kick you
have to do a kick and then a Sprint and
then a dribble and a tackle and there
are studies to back up the fact that
this works it's called the interference
principle and in one study it was found
that when trading basketball or netball
for example if you get people to just
perform drills of say hoop shots or
drills of dribbling then they won't
learn as quickly as if you mix those
things up if you mix things up they
might perform worse during the training
session but they then actually perform
better out in the field another study
found that baseball players when
provided with more variability in their
training they were then able to tap into
this and perform better as the
researchers put it they were better able
to solve coordination challenges
foreign
at this point you're just jumping around
like a goofy idiot that's not going to
build any muscle well first of all
muscle isn't always necessarily the main
goal if you're interested in Dynamic
performance and control and Mobility as
we've talked about this is actually one
of the best ways to develop that at the
same time it actually can build muscle
you just need to choose your exercises
correctly so a burpee is not
particularly well suited to building
strength max strength nor is it well
suited to building hypertrophy muscle
gain obvious reason because you're not
spending long enough in either position
at the same time you're already
switching between the two there's not
much metabolic build up there's not
enough cross bridging because it's a
kind of plyometric movement however if
you choose exercises to string together
that's focused on the same or very
similar muscle groups then there's no
reason that you can't build muscle using
a more interesting and varied selection
of exercises something I would like to
point out is that I do these exercises
very fast explosive manner I'm doing
silly things like head Springs and
kip-ups and kick degrees you don't have
to do all that stuff just combining a
couple of exercises and Performing them
in a slow and more controlled manner
with a full range of motion is also a
really good way of doing this so another
one I really like and it's in the
protein performance system in quite a
big way is the Renegade row so if you've
not done a renegade road before what
you're going to do is take two dumbbells
put them on the ground roughly where you
put your hands if you're doing push-ups
put your feet up behind you a little bit
wider apart than usual and then you're
just going to row dumbbells up to you
like so these are slightly light and you
can of course
do push-ups in between
because well
why wouldn't you really the Renegade row
is really an awesome movement and
especially if they're that push-up in
between reps there that's because it's a
horizontal push and a horizontal pull in
a single exercise and a lot of us don't
get that many horizontal pulling
movements in our exercise diet anyways
especially if you do primarily body
weight stuff or just train with
dumbbells so this is a really great way
to get that and at the same time when
you want just one arm it's also
anti-rotation because you've got to
avoid your body twisting back down
towards the ground so again here you're
getting a real bang for your buck with a
single exercise another exercise where
you start in a push-up position using
dumbbells is the devil press and here
what you're basically doing is
performing a push-up holding dumbbells
on the ground giving you a greater range
of motion then as though you're going to
do a burpee you jump up and then stand
up and you're going to press the weights
overhead this time this time you've once
again got a push-up in there but now
you've also got an overhead press as
well so it's got a horizontal push and a
vertical push as well as a small amount
of squatting and if you want to take
this even further then you have the man
maker and the man maker combines the
Renegade row with the devil press so
you're going to perform a renegade row
jump up and then press the weight
overhead and you've got just so much
stuff anti-fructation you've got
horizontal pull the horizontal push
you've got an overhead push all kinds of
good stuff and it'll Really Leave You
exhausted pretty quickly as well
kettlebells of course
using a kettlebell is the crossbody
clean and press you've seen me talk
about it before you can start with the
Kettlebell by one foot then with the
opposite arm bend down twisting pick it
up and then you're going to get it into
the racked position and then press it
overhead so this time you've not only
got a slight hinge a slight squat but
also an overhead press and a pull and
what this is going to teach you among
other things is to pick things up off
the ground whilst twisting which is
actually something we do an awful lot in
the real world but it's not represented
that much within our usual training
routine so it's a great one to
incorporate in there as well okay so
it's really raining now so probably time
I left but if you enjoy this kind of
training then check out my ebook and
training program super functional
training 2.0 also comes with over two
hours of instructional video that
includes a whole bunch of these hybrid
exercises from the devil press and man
makers and Renegade rows to the
crossbody clean and press you name it
not only that but it also shows you
another way to train with multiple
different movements in a single set that
being the mechanical drop set in fact
that's one of the cornerstones that the
training program is built on either way
thank you so much for watching this one
guys I really appreciate it see you
later
and bye for now